where the floods came and never left
abandoned Villages now dot the landscape
in southern Pakistan's synth Province
damaged buildings are all that's left of
this school a once thriving Community
reduced to a swamp
to help families recover UNICEF is
focusing on creating safe spaces for
women and children they have become a
place to deliver services and raise
awareness about hygiene and social
issues
in terms of child protection there were
a number of cases among our flood
affected children such as rape cases
where kids would run away from home
looking for food but they wouldn't know
if a person was going to give them food
or abuse them
community outreach programs encourage
people to come forward and more
incidents are being reported if any
incident got Farber then happened in the
communities so the first thing which is
coming as a shame to the victim they
call it there must be a reason that's
why it happened to him so we are
discouraging that thing and we are
promoting awareness that it's not an
individual issue so we need to highlight
and we need to Pro give a protective
environment to our children's so we are
openly discussing there's things and we
are shaming to the people who are doing
this kind of Acts many of the children
here especially girls are going to
school for the first time to change
mindsets on child marriage and child
labor trust must be earned
a community
people don't want to educate their girls
where there is a male teacher they don't
feel comfortable the advantage of a
female teacher is parents give
permission more easily for their
daughters to go to the school they feel
more comfortable with them nearly half
of all children in flood affected areas
show signs of trauma anxiety depression
and other mental health problems
these schools are a space for them to
develop coping mechanisms and to heal
pre-floods classrooms were not
dissimilar to rudimentary structures
like this one these tents are a real
upgrade and the next step is Brick and
Mortar School houses
successful education programs in rural
areas the UN says can Empower an entire
generation
enrollment has increased by an estimated
300 percent compared to before the
floods
places that offer young people a better
future but also give children a chance
to be children
Zain Bas Ravi Al Jazeera netherwasan
synth Province Pakistan